Speaker 1: A lying Republican now
says that when you call out her lies,
you're being anti-Hispanic. This is exactly
the nonsense that the right accuses the left
of doing. I will remind you that there is this
new Republican congresswoman and Paulina Luna.
She lied about being Jewish. We talked
about it yesterday. She's not actually
Jewish. She has since been called out for
her lies. She says to Charlie Kirk during
an appearance yesterday that when her lies
are called out, it is anti Hispanic. That's
an interesting perspective. Let's listen.
Speaker 3: And to say that I would make
something like that up. Why would they say that?
It's because they don't want young Hispanics to
be reputable. And if you look at the slant
of the entire article, they say that I'm not
Hispanic enough, even though they cite where my
grandparents immigrated from. But, you know, a lot
of what they do is character assassination. And if
you don't have the spine for it, you can fall. But
I think that we launched a full frontal assault
and we'll look forward to more retraction soon.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Despite the claims of
Republicans, it is actually Republicans who
regularly play the victim card. This is another
example of accusations or confessions. This is
another example of projection. This is another
example of the right developing a narrative about
the left that applies more to them than it does
to the left. Republicans often claim that the left
always their victims were victims of racism,
say the leftists were victims of xenophobia,
were victims of sexism. The leftists, they
want to be victims. But when you actually look,
you see that Republicans have been playing the
victims for a long time now. The war on Christmas,
the Christians were being victimized, the war on
religion. The claims aren't backed by evidence.
They use them to rally their base. They use them
to raise money. They use them to purport to be
the victims of some liberal agenda. Oh, if you're
straight, you're now being attacked just for being
straight. Another example, they say we're victims
of election fraud. There is no evidence to support
that. And in fact, when individual perpetrators
of so-called election fraud are found, they are
almost always Republicans either trying to test
the system or simply trying to vote multiple
times. They say the left does it there. They're
the ones getting caught doing it. Okay. They said
an entire election was stolen from them. Trump's
new thing. Oh, no. Nobody's been treated more
unfairly than my family, all my friends. Do you
have friends? All my friends tell me nobody's been
treated as unfairly as you have. But the left,
they're the ones who play the victim. And then,
of course, they often claim to be the victims
of discrimination. Or sometimes they'd like to
use the term reverse discrimination or reverse
racism or whatever the case may be. And yet,
when you actually look at studies, you find that
it is people of color, communities of color,
marginalized groups who are more likely to
actually be discriminated against. And so by
claiming to be the victims of discrimination,
they they deny the experiences of people who
are actually the victims of discrimination.
They distract from real issues. And of course,
they become that which they criticize the
left for being. And this is yet another
example. They're going after me for being
Hispanic. No, they're going after you for
being a liar. That's what this is. At the end
of the day. And so I don't really know the best
strategy for the left on this, because if you're
on the left and you identify an injustice,
you've gone woke. You're playing the victim card,
whatever. But then when they do it themselves and
we call it out because the right doesn't care
about hypocrisy anymore, or if they ever did,
and because the right has abandoned policy, their
voters don't actually care. They fall for. Yeah,
they're going after Anna Paulina Luna because
she's a proud conservative Hispanic woman. No,
they're going after her because she's a
liar and she deserves it. Quite simply,